>> Sean: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM TONIGHT
INTRODUCING A NEW RESOLUTION
CONDEMNING THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, THEIR
CLOSED-DOOR, ILLEGITIMATE,
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY, HE JOINS US NOW IS MORE
PAID SENATOR, I'M GLAD TO SEE
THIS HAPPEN.
EVERY REPUBLICAN THAT WAS THERE
VOTED FOR IT YET YESTERDAY.
DEMOCRAT SHUT IT DOWN.
NEVER BEFORE HAS THIS HAPPENED
IN AN IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
CLOSED DOORS.
THEY WON'T EVEN LET A REPUBLICAN
READ A TRANSCRIPT WITHOUT A
REMINDER, AND GOD FORBID THEY
GET A COPY OF IT.
>> YEAH, SO THIS RESOLUTION PUTS
THE SENATE ON RECORD CONDEMNING
THE HOUSE FOR THE FUTURE OF THE
PRESIDENCY.
WE CANNOT ALLOW FUTURE
PRESIDENTS AND THIS PRESIDENT TO
BE IMPEACHED BASED ON AN INQUIRY
IN THE HOUSE THAT'S NEVER BEEN
VOTED UPON THAT DOES NOT ALLOW
THE PRESIDENT AND THE WITNESS
AGAINST HIM TO CALL WHEN IT'S ON
HIS BEHALF AND CROSS-EXAMINE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACCUSING HIM OF
MISDEEDS.
ALL I'M ASKING IS GIVE
DONALD TRUMP THE SAME RIGHTS AS
RICHARD AND RICHARD NIXON AND
BILL CLINTON HAD WHEN IT COMES
TO IMPEACHMENT.
I'M INSISTING THAT DONALD TRUMP
BE GIVEN THE SAME RIGHTS THAT
ANY AMERICAN HAS AT WHEN YOU'RE
GIVING A PARKING TICKET TO
CONFRONT THE WITNESSES AGAINST
YOU, CAN'T BE BASED ON HEARSAY,
AND HERE'S THE POINT OF
RESOLUTION.
ANY IMPEACHMENT VOTE BASED ON
THIS PROCESS, TO ME, IS
ILLEGITIMATE, IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, AND SHOULD BE
DISMISSED IN SENATE WITHOUT A
TRIAL.
>> Sean: OKAY.
NOW.
SO LET'S WALK THROUGH HOW DO I
GET STUNNED AT HOW DO YOU
DISMISS IT WITHOUT A TRIAL?
ALL OF WHAT YOU ARE SAYING IS
TRUE.
NEW JOINT GETTING NEWT GINGRICH
JOINS US IN A MINUTE.
AND HE WILL EXPLAIN EVERY
DETAIL.
YOU SAID THE CORNER OF AMERICA
IS DURO STUDENTS, DUE PROCESS, C
IS DURO STUDENTS, DUE PROCESS, A
IS DURO STUDENTS, DUE PROCESS, L
IS DURO STUDENTS, DUE PROCESS, N
IS DURO STUDENTS, DUE PROCESS, E
IS DURO STUDENTS, DUE PROCESS, T
ACCUSATIONS AGAINST YOU.
NONE OF THAT IS HAPPENING IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES AND
WHERE ARE YOUR FELLOW SENATORS?
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THEM SIGN
YOUR LETTER.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE A RESOLUTION
BE IT I WOULD HOPE TO HAVE A
VOTE ON IT.
I HOPE --
IT WOULD BE GREAT TO HAVE 100.
COULD YOU IMAGINE IF REPUBLICANS
WERE DOING THIS TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT?
DOES OPENING BY BILL TAYLOR
TODAY, EVERYBODY IS BREATHLESS.
HERE'S THE QUESTION.
WHY DOES THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE DENY THERE IS A QUID PRO
QUO?
WHAT DO YOU KNOW THAT HE DOESN'T
KNOW?
WHY DID THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UKRAINE'S EGG DURING THE, I
DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS FUNDED AND
THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE, THE
ALLEGED VICTIM, DENIES THERE
IS A QUID PRO QUO, HE DIDN'T
FEEL THREATENED BY THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
THAT ONLY HAPPENS IF YOU CAN
CONFRONT THE WITNESSES AGAINST
YOU.
THIS PROCESS IN THE HOUSE IS
BEING CONDUCTED BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS, REPUBLICANS ARE BEING
SHUT OUT, AND IF YOU HAD AN
INQUIRY VOTE, THAT ALLOWS
REPUBLICANS AND A PRESIDENT TO
CALL WITNESSES AND TO CONFRONT
PEOPLE ACCUSING THE PRESIDENT OF
MISDEEDS.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED WITH
CLINTON, THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED
WITH NIXON AND ANDREW JOHNSON.
THIS IS UN-AMERICAN AT ITS
CORPORATE WITH THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES IS DOING IS A
PROCESS, OF POLITICAL REVENGE.
IT IS ALIEN TO AMERICAN DUE
PROCESS.
IT SHOULD BE DISMISSED QUICKLY
IN THE UNITED STATES SENATE SO
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF THEY
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT BASED ON
THIS CLOSED-DOOR,
BEHIND-THE-SCENES, LACK OF DUE
PROCESS, INQUIRY?
WE SHOULD DISMISS IT WITHOUT A
TRIAL BECAUSE IT'S ILLEGITIMATE
ON ITS FACE AND IF IT IS ALLOWED
TO STAND, THERE IS NO PROTECTION
FOR FUTURE PRESIDENTS.
>> Sean: WHEN THE PRESIDENT
SAYS, AND WE WENT OVER THIS,
WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAYS CAN YOU
DO ME A FAVOR?
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED HUNDREDS OF
TIMES THAT HAPPENS TO BE ONE OF
THE PRESIDENT'S TRANSITION
PHRASES AND WE HAVE THE
TAPE.
CAN YOU DO ME A FAVOR.
MANY TALKS ABOUT THE 2016
ELECTION INTERFERENCE OF UKRAINE
CONFIRMED BY POLITICO, 2017,
JANUARY.
IT ISN'T ALSO ONE OF HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTIES, HIS SWORN
OATH, TO FAITHFULLY EXECUTE THE
LAWS OF THE LAND AND I JUST
HEARD EVERYONE SO UPSET ABOUT
ELECTION INTERFERENCE AND TROMP
AND RUSSIA, I WOULD THINK THEY
WOULD BE ON BOARD WANTING TO
HELP TRUMP GET TO THE TRUTH BUT
THAT'S NOT THE CASE, IS IT?
>> NOT WANTED DEMOCRAT HAS
SUGGESTED THE PRESIDENT IS
TREATED UNFAIRLY WHEN IT
VIOLATES EVERY BASIC PRINCIPLE O
VIOLATES EVERY BASIC PRINCIPLE F
VIOLATES EVERY BASIC PRINCIPLE D
VIOLATES EVERY BASIC PRINCIPLE E
PROCESS.
WE GAVE ABOUT $400 MILLION HERE
TO THE UKRAINE AND IN AID AND
HERE'S THE QUESTION.
IS THE POLITICO ARTICLE ACCURATE
IS?
IS SOMEBODY LOOKING AT THE DNC
INVOLVEMENT IN 2016 AS THEY
LOOKED AT TROND AND RUSSIA?
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO DO THAT.
SO IT'S NOT ON FOUNDED FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
UKRAINE INTERFERENCE AND IN OUR
ELECTION IF HE BELIEVES THE
POLITICO ARTICLE BUT HERE'S THE
POINT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
IMPEACHMENT OF THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, DESTROYING A
MANDATE FROM THE PEOPLE, A
POLITICAL DEATH SENTENCE, AND HE
IS NOT ENTITLED TO KNOW WHO IS
ACCUSES ARE.
HE CAN'T CALL A WITNESS ON HIS
BEHALF AND HE CAN'T
CROSS-EXAMINE THOSE WHO ARE